I want to illustrate one more thing with our, somewhat silly, I guess, really
silly example which allows us to get even more reuse, which is our real goal
with inheritance. So, both the GrizzlyBear and the BlackBear classes have chase
methods. And what these methods do is pretty similar. If the victim is up the
tree. They do something different. The GrizzlyBear knocks down the tree, the
BlackBear climbs the tree. Otherwise, they do the same thing. So, we'd really
like to reuse almost all of this code and assuming there's chase people too and
what we'd really like to do is move the shared parts of the chase method into
Bear and only deal with the special case, where the victim's up the tree in
GrizzlyBear and BlackBear. Here's one way we might deal with this, which is to
use the built in isinstance operator. And this returns true if the object is an
instance of the class or one of its supertypes. Otherwise, it returns false.